matt's in charlotte north carolina hey
matt welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so i'm really looking for some uh
workplace advice i
i have a kind of a negative workplace a
little bit of a toxic environment
but i get paid really well so
with some of the things kind of going on
my wife's pushing me to look for
different
opportunities but we're
not in the position the last dollar was
in but we're really good financial
uh position what do you make we're
um right now about 160. what's toxic
um they're they're really profit driven
it's not really about the employees it's
about how much the employees can kind of
make for them
it's uh very recently i've had some
people hired underneath me that are
really
there to kind of do my job but
i'm responsible for them and i wasn't
involved in their hiring
there's some other kind of anti-mentors
you know as
phrases i've heard but the people that
i'm supposed to be
working with that are really um
not really team players are not looking
looking out for themselves not
not for the group um is is creating a
lot of challenges with with my job
why can't you go get a job in the same
field making the same money with a good
company
um so some of the opportunities that
i've found
and i have been looking um they're not
at the level that i'm making now it's
i am at a really good position i've
worked my way up in
uh in this company so while i'm not
wouldn't be taking
like a 20 drop it would still be under
what i would be making now
like how much um
and probably uh i think one of the ones
i looked at there
was maybe the high 120s versus 160. okay
yeah so my question matt is
do you want to leave or does your wife
want you to leave
is it that bad to where you were already
going that direction
so i i love my career and i love the
people i work with other
you know the ones that i've kind of
mentioned um
if those things were different i would
there would not be an option i would be
there
uh i would stay so okay let me ask you a
question let me ask you a leadership
question
what i heard you say is there are some
people that were hired that are
underneath of you
you had nothing to do in the hiring
process it's a little bit grey to me as
to
how that decision is being made do you
think that there is
a healthy of enough leadership structure
that you could talk to your leaders
about this or have you already done that
and the cans been kicked down the road
so that's exactly the situation where i
have uh
talked to them about it brought up these
type of situations uh
and they're just kind of kicking them
down the road they're brushing them off
all right well that's to me that's a
sign
that's a sign yeah i listen i i think
you got to be patient
you're not in a true toxic situation
where your health is
is under attack and you're dealing with
all kinds of anxiety and stuff
i would keep looking i would also set
your sights a little higher and i would
also not worry about taking a temporary
cut as long as you can absorb it and it
doesn't
really challenge your budget and put you
in a totally different position if you
feel like you can get
on another ladder that has a temporary
cut
i'm okay with it but don't settle for
that i wouldn't assume that someone of
your pay your experience
uh and your ability and desire to win
couldn't get something
equally or better i'd keep looking i
look a little harder and i'd bite the
stick a little bit
put up with this a little longer until i
found the best opportunity
that'd be my advice